je n'oublierai jamais le jour du 17
février où l'hôpital m'a appelé en
urgence j'ai trouvé mon fils nathan dans
son lit avec une personne debout en
train de le masser il en était à son
deuxième arrêt cardiaque de la soirée
c'est la dernière image que j'ai de mon
fils au départ j'ai eu vraiment eu un
sentiment de culpabilité parce que j'ai
nourri mon enfant je lui ai donné cette
pizza j'ai eu le sentiment d' assassiner
mon fils moi j'ai fait des enfants pour
en prendre soin j'ai pas fait un enfant
pour qu'il soit mort à 8 ans en fait
suite à ces témoignages et la met en
cause vers ans qui a été on peut pas on
va pas se mentir à ses silences et sur
la sphère regard des faits depuis 18
ferrer mon enfant est parti tous les
jours je trouve la force de me lever
mais c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui on est dans le pays où quand
il ya des enfants qui meurent parce que
des industriels ne respectent pas les
règles ont fait rien monsieur vérone n'a
rien fait on attend tous qui prennent la
parole et qu'il arrête de se défiler et
que des sanctions soient mis à
l'encontre des industriels qui ne
respectent pas les règles prendre
position pour qui est des actions fortes
et que tout ça n'arrive plus en fait et
suite à ce témoignage finalement le
ministre la santé monsieur vers en a
parlé c'était je crois sur bfm regardez
je suis dévasté pour le décès de ce
petit johan eu deux enfants qui sont
morts d'avoir mangé une pizza ce papa a
raison et je m'associe pleinement ses
douleurs je vous assure que c'est c'est
poignant et ça s'apprend les lignes de
production des pizzas ont été
immédiatement suspendu c'était le 6
avril lusine de caudry dans le nord ne
peut plus fabriquer des pizzas la
justice a été immédiatement saisie une
perquisition a eu lieu dans les locaux
de l'entreprise et la justice devra
aller maintenant de mener son enquête
moi je suis ministre en charge de la
santé donc tout ce qui pouvait être fait
en matière de conditions sanitaires pour
faire en sorte qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
cas de contamination toutes ces mesures
ont été prises immédiatement mais dès
qu'il ya une alerte bon c'est un peu
mais c'est pas vrai on peut pas attendre
trois mois pour s'exprimer et a fallu
qui est cet homme en larmes qui nous
raconte son histoire qui est terrible ce
témoignage il est absolument
bouleversant fin on est pour la plupart
parents ici imaginez qu'on qu'on peut
tuer son enfant lui donnant une pizza à
cette terrible et est ministre qui
attend on ne sait pas ce en février il
parlant non mais attendez on en sait il
mais je sais pourquoi il est d'un très
bien que maintenant c est quoi il ya
trois mois le début de la campagne
présidentielle donc il faut les
giboulées j'en ai rien à [ __ ] pardon
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] excuse moi tu
penses à un parent qui a perdu son
enfant mais la campagne présidentielle
mais qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] il
faut tous fermés pour prendre des
décisions les industriels ils se sont
même pas exprimé enfin au début puis
tognon là on avait reçu ici là vraiment
d'une petite fille qui était malade elle
nous disait que but tony ne l'avait même
pas contactés une seule fois enfin je
veux dire on marche sur la tête on
idéalise vous savez ce qu'est ce qui se
dit sur la politique de communication
but tony c'est que comme pour la faire
fergus avec lait les viandes de chevaux
il se dit voilà ça va ça va s'estomper
et puis on verra bien ce qui se passe
dans dentier suis moi c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a oublié
par nul si tout le monde remonte du sein
du ce donc je pense que c'est sûr ça
qu'ils disent mais là le problème c'est
qu'il y aura une vraie enquête et
visiblement ça a passé au ministre de la
justice dont qui se refilent un petit
peu le bébé quand même la tempe et la
justice c'est ce sens peut défiler
honnêtement c'est une histoire
épouvantable c'est intolérable vraiment
mais il faut s'attaquer aux industriels
faut avoir peur avant le dîner lassé des
grands groupes et c'est eux qui
devraient parler avant le min est excusé
mais vraiment mais c'est la marque qui
devrait s'exprimer avant le ministre
c'est ça l'urgence que le ministre y
parle d'un fait mais comment s'assurer
que les industriels n'ont pas encore
pris la parole je suis là que j'entends
ce que vous dites mais aujourd'hui c'est
on peut pas l'entendre sa non merde moi
si je vous dis ce qui se dit en termes
de croissance et que comme n'y a pas
grand chose à dire comment expliquer
l'inexplicable on le voit c'est que je
faisais déjà s'excuser contacter les
familles des damoiselles mais entourer
les familles à ceux-là c'est une sont
des réunions de crise entouré des
familles prendre tous les toutes les
décisions importantes
barras a aujourd'hui on sait pas ce
qu'ils ont décidé ce qu'ils ont fait et
si se sente responsable de quoi que ce
soit c'est ça le truc est grave
guillaume lui donnez vous était plutôt
modérateur aux médias oui après la
situation allait évoluer à plus en plus
de cas qui sont extrêmement graves ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya un manque de
communication de terrible de la part de
la marque mais aussi du gouvernement je
trouve et qui amène à ce sentiment de
culpabilité des familles qui est juste
enfin horrible où on se retrouve être le
père qu'ils y voient là de ma faute que
c'est moi qui ai tué mon fils donc là en
ce sens là oui la marque de communiquer
expliquer et c'est certainement pas à ce
monsieur de se sentir coupable il faut
que la marque communique ses traits à un
peu sur va pas se mentir c'est parce que
ce sont souvent des produits qui sont
pas très cher pour une fois mais j'ai
toujours les mêmes qui trinquent
c'est parce que voir pour son aspect une
pizza plutôt congelés surgelés il a fait
80 la vue la confection de ses pizzas
ségalas moi je n'achète plus moi j'ai
acheté c'est fini oui elle en 2006
parler du chocolat aussi je vais je peux
citer la marque ou pas oui la rigueur
oui
extraordinaire des campagnes depuis deux
ans les glaces de la marque sur toutes
les nouvelles les nouvelles les nouveaux
produits qui vont sortir mais en
revanche n'a rien rien sur tout ce qui a
été contamination on ne s'excuse pas on
n'en parle pas moi j'aimerais que les
marques face justement une campagne de
pub où elles disent voilà on a merdé et
il faut que ça mais moi aussi con parce
que si j'avais productif juste le
problème que dans ce cas il faut penser
qu'il ya des gens qui bossent et à tout
ça donc pour parler de 2,2 kinder etc
ferrero c est une entreprise gigantesque
qui avaient fait massivement selon
publicité donc tout n'est pas si c'est
passé pas blanc et noirs oui plein doute
nous c'est pareil c'est tout un secteur
s'est déplacé les plats préparés c'est
des pizzas donc hissé des dizaines des
centaines d'emplois donc comment faire
pour y remédier à ces millions qui sont
mis dans la com et dans la publicité est
ce que si on avait quelques millions
justement pour la prévention pour nous
aider pour pour aller voir aussi les
familles qui ont été victimes jeudi
en pleine crise tas de stratégie en
communication de crise soit tu ne dis
rien et tout laisse passer soit tu te
positionnant les médias qui occupent le
terrain et du ferme la porte au débat
c'est exactement ça ce qui est en train
de se passer à l'égout tony c'est à dire
qu'ils nous prennent pas ils attendent
que ça se passe
proposition 2 2 3 4 5
vous avez surtout d'être employé qui
dénonce les problèmes d'hygiène chez
mito ni depuis des années donc je veux
dire on n'est même pas dans une une
question de réunions de crise oui c'est
aujourd'hui la marque elle doit prendre
la parole et images on m'avait bien dit
comment vous voulez qu'ils vivent avec
ça et que ça c'est tout ça va jamais
s'étouffer à la sortie de ces photos la
marque a simplement dire d'habitude
c'est pas aussi sa loi les
communications non mais je vous jure je
vous jure je d'accord mais munication
bon je ne sais quoi c'est que ces
quelques dirigeants qui ont donné des
instructions de rentabilité alors
surveillez donc les employés pour aller
là bas c'est un faussaire est terrible
vous devez nous fûmes sur tout ce qui
n'est pas la production vraiment donc
tout ce qui est nettoyage et tout ça
pour faire des marges n'est donc mais là
il faudrait qu'on nous disait ce qu'il
ya des têtes qui sont tombés pour
on
fait un point il ya un juge qui était
inquiété d'un médecin qui vont mener une
enquête mois qui vont auditionner les
les bonnes choses et c'est plutôt ce qui
est extrêmement rare qu'ils veulent une
enquête qui va être mené dans cette
cuisine je pense au sein du siège du but
tony et même au dessus puisque ça fait
parti d'un énorme groupe c numéro un
mondiale cdc
voilà donc c'est un groupe considère
qu'il faut faire des perquisitions il
comprend des dossiers est normalement
certains ne devraient pas manquer du
doigt et donc inculpés et je rappelle
que pour l'instant il est inculpé
d'homicide involontaire et de
distribution de produits j'ai pas de
avariés ou périmés petite précision
quand si vous trouvez encore des
fraîcheurs parce qu'il y en a encore
parlé hier et encore alors c'est pas
bétonner qu'irresponsable séléné d'aînés
l'estrie buteurs qui ont des stocks
importants et qui tentent de les
fourriers donc donc voilà donc fait
attention c'est alors c'est pas bientôt
nigon a vendu sais ce qu'ils valent à
ceux qui en avaient en stock ils veulent
a tranquillement
dh de vie non mais j'oublie
ce sont des stocks typhoïde je pense que
rien personne ne va pour l'éthique de
responsabilité pénale chéché chez ces
personnes qui ont décidé d'écouler leur
stock c'est ça le problème oculaire ce
qui est grave c'est sociale c'est pour
ça qu'il vous reparler de la forme c'est
quitte ou tout ce qui traîne aujourd'hui
comme l'eau de fraîcheur notamment chez
sont des lots qui ont été achetés avant
pendant ou après et qui ont été stockés
et qu'il faut éliminer voilà
le
ramener au magasin se faire rembourser
n'avait pas voulu jeter c'est vrai
j'aime voulait jeter voiture amène peu
touchés se faire rembourser ils ont
aussi une responsabilité pénale parce
qu'à partir le monde tu es au courant
c'était au courant nicolas du rif pour
celui
du risque tu fais une mise en danger
dans alors la vérité c'est quoi c'est
que tant qu'il y aura pas d à des
amendes de plusieurs millions d'euros ce
genre de groupe laisse couler la sphère
est bannie avant qu'ils soient mis en
cause il va passer